okay guys we can start to make a big
change here but we have less than a day
to do it so listen up
yesterday fight for the future informed
us that the Copyright Office is looking
for feedback on the DMCA whether or not
it has helped or harm the internet as a
whole this took us by surprise
apparently has flown right under the
radar it's right now if you take a look
at the comments there's only 80 there's
barely any there at all this is our
chance to let the government know what's
been going on with fair use and
strangely enough the date that they're
gonna cut it off and not let you do the
comments anymore and stuff is April 1st
April Fool's Day so I have to emphasize
this is not at April Fool's jokes cross
my heart everything this is for real
this is something every YouTube creator
every viewer just anyone that's on the
internet needs to comment on and there's
not a lot of time to do it with where's
the fair use so many people have
verbalized how much the DMCA is being
abused with these false claims everybody
is either made a video or know somebody
that's made of video that if it went to
court it'd be deemed fair use but it was
taken down anyway this is your chance to
let Washington know what's going on and
how incredibly day did this processes
the DMCA was signed into law on October
28 1998 it was created to protect
copyright holders rights as well as
websites who host content if a website
gets a DMCA takedown they must take down
the content related to the DMCA here's
the problem it hasn't been updated to
account for today's internet back in
1998 the internet was far different many
big sites were created and many of them
failed we backed up our data on floppy
disks and we now use the cloud many of
us use the internet for all our
entertainment and the DMCA was written
for the 1998 Internet one of which a
site like YouTube was nothing more than
a fantasy news stations aren't the only
ones who can break news now an average
person with a cell phone can break the
news before they can the Internet has
changed so much in those 18 years yet
one of the major laws around it has
become a fossil the DMCA
fails to account for the Internet of
today instead of it being used to
protect the content creators that you
watch and love it's now being used to
harass
and even destroy those content creators
this is a chance for us to band together
and protect the internet that we love
and bring it to the one place that can
protect it as a whole until we get
strict penalties in place for false DMCA
takedown that YouTube is always going to
be under attack and so will the Internet
this is our chance to bring the fight
out of YouTube and into Washington DC if
you look below fight for the future has
created a website so that you can send
comments to the government right now
in fact it needs to be right now this
page contains a form letter that you can
edit to explain how the DMCA has
affected you mention how people file
claims on content that they don't even
own mention that DMCA s are being used
to inflict harm on individual creators
and they are being used to stifle free
speech mention how people just talking
on camera with no copyright footage or
music are being taken down mention that
some companies believe they create the
law mention that DMCA s are being used
without factoring in fair use mention
that DMCA's are being sent by shell
companies to shield the company sending
the takedowns mention how people use
them as threats mention that videos are
getting hit multiple times even after
they're cleared if you're a creator
mentioned how your DMCA takedown
resulted in lost revenue and harassment
this was not our original plan next move
for where's the fair use but it is
incredibly important we have a short
amount of time to really make our voices
heard here so definitely send a comment
call send them emails and let them know
that this needs to be fixed the battle
we're about to embark on is not gonna be
a short one but we're in it for the long
haul we know that this is gonna require
a lot more calls to action but this
needs to be done to protect content on
the internet all of our content whether
you're trying to just upload pictures or
entertain someone we're all at risk this
has been shown by all the invalid
takedowns in the past while the current
entertainment industry's have the money
we have the numbers the internet
defeated SOPA the internet defeated PIPA
let's put an end to these type of bills
and secure the internet for the present
and the future let's begin the process
to fix copyright law and bring it into
the 21st century we're witnessing a
cultural shift in entertainment that was
last seen by our grandparents and
our great-grandparents the last time
this happened was in the 1950s the
Internet through Internet enabled
devices will become the norm for
watching content as more and more people
abandoned cable and satellite we need to
make sure that the industry that has
such a hard time accepting new
technology can't continue its reign of
exorbitant prices and anti-competitive
practices we genuinely don't ask people
to share our videos but with this we
really need you to share with as many
people as you can and as quickly as you
can
links for everything we've talked about
art below definitely check them out this
is our chance to finally start fixing
YouTube comment call an email we only
have until 11:59 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time on April 1st that's not much time
go make your voice heard